hello everyone and welcome to a very
nice game you guys requested it's from
round two of this year's Char Jack
Masters and it is a pretty big upset one
of the reasons why you guys requested it
it is world number 20 visit centers
Gujarati versus women's world champion
uh juwenjun uh you can see there's quite
a bit of a rating difference almost 200
rating points and um uh in in terms in
terms of um uh starting points in the
tournament for example with it is seed
number three uh Only Ones rated higher
than him or gookish and para maxulo and
the Jew engine is a seed number 70. so
uh that being said let's check out the
game and how uh well the the Women's
World Champion uh juven June played this
game so with it has the white pieces and
he opens with Ponte E4 we have Pawn to
E5 Knight to F3 Knight to C6 and Bishop
to C4 we have Bishop to C5 and I know
what you guys are thinking but no it is
not that time just yet we have Pawn to
D3 and now Knight to F6 so the standard
The Joker pianissimo with castles and
Ponte D6 with Pawn to C3 uh we have uh
A6 now uh Ponte A4 and H6 so pretty
standard stuff here Rook to E1 and now
uh dual engine just castles I uh
sometimes I will mention this in a
position
um
uh of the start that Knight the G4
although you can play this now that Rook
FT1 has been played uh because the F
Pawn is being threatened but rookie 2 is
perfectly fine for white you don't have
to worry about this next move whatever
black plays you're just gonna kick away
the Knight and once the Knight moves uh
you can go B4 and just go on with your
business you don't really care about
this you don't uh have to worry about
Bishop G4 so The Rook is actually very
nicely placed on E1 later on you can
easily uh easily just double up so it's
not a problem and no one will ever play
Knights to G4 of course until someone
does so here we have Rook the uh we have
castles Ponte H3 now stopping the bishop
G4 and the bishop to A7 we have Knight V
to D2 and she goes for Bishop to E6 if
it is just trades here with Bishop
captures Pawn captors and now Pawn to B4
as one always should we have Knight the
H5 now and look at this position now of
course the white has very nice expansion
on the queen side very nice central
control uh but look at the bishop here
look at The Rook here the queen is
coming there six then you will maybe
even double up or triple up on the file
the Knight is coming to F4 it just
doesn't seem like something one or you
know should prefer playing over let's
say something like the Evans Gambit but
okay we have Knight to F1 uh we have
Queen to F6 and now Rook Day to a very
nice
and I move the Rook will now serve as
the defender of the F2 Pawn so the
Knight maybe can even move uh Knight to
F4 and now King the H2 uh the this still
is a known position for example uh uh a
certain game from 2019 from the world
Blitz Champion a reached this exact same
position uh maximum drew his game
against
um uh Vladimir kramnik but here we have
King to H2 by visit uh and now there are
a couple of moves that reach this
possession but here we have Rook to F7
and it is now as of move 15 that we have
a completely new game so here he
continues with Ponta B5 Knight D7 and
now B captures an A6 we have B captures
and A6 and now Bishop to E3 offering a
trade of Bishops and she declined she
just plays Pawn to C5 and only now that
this diagonal has been closed the video
plays Bishop captures on F4 we have
Queen captures an F4 with check King the
H1 and now Queen back to F6 we have
Knight the E3 now with the ideas of
maybe like the C4 or even Knight to G4
and just Knights the G6 now the other
Knight is coming to F4 and while you
could play Knight to G4 it looks very
nice it just um
and once the queen moves the Knight
really serves no purpose on G4 uh so
instead we have rooked the B2 nicely
controlling the B file while also
keeping an eye on that F2 pawn and here
just Rook 8 to f8 nicely tripling up on
the f file we have Knights the G1 and
now uh uh here we have Queen to G5 the
queen moves out of the way so you can
now actually capture on F2 so how can we
stop Rook captures on F2 well one way to
do it and it seems like a pretty
reasonable thing to do is spawn to F3
but the problem with Pawn to F3 is this
Pawn to C4 move now the Knight is
hanging and how do you defend this you
can play Knight captures on C4 but then
Pawn to D5 comes and once the Knight
moves then you have to deal with ideas
like Bishop to E3 Bishop to F4 Queen G3
some Queen quintage to Checkmate IDs
looks very very ugly for white so
instead with it plays Queen to G4 his
idea is okay if Queens get traded the
Knight will also be defending on F2 but
it doesn't look like it actually works
because the Knight can just be kicked
away and the F2 Pawn will hang so it
seems that Vita loses the pawn
regardless of what he does
now uh you have to also consider do you
do capture an F2 right away or do you
trade Queens the problem with capturing
is that Queen captures an E6 comes with
check for example Rook captures Queen
captures an E6 check King H7 and now
Rook B7 and all of a sudden you have a
you have a very double-edged game it
doesn't look like something you uh you
want to play uh but so instead after
this queen to G4 move uh Juve engine
just trades Queen captures and G4 we
have Knight captures and G4 okay the
pawn is defended but now Pawn to H5 just
kicking away the defender of the F2 Pawn
so Knight back to E3 and The Rook
captures on F2 we have rooked to B7 yeah
so with it trades the pawn for some
activity for his Rook but his other
pieces aren't very active to complement
The Rook on B7 we have Rook 2 back to F7
you have to defend the bishop here and
now he trades Rook captures King
captures and now Knights the C4 now the
Knight is going after the D6 pawn and
King the E7 nicely defends that we have
Knight to F3 and now Knights the F4
going after the D3 Pawn as well and the
vivid's position is just um
uh incredibly difficult to play now he
should probably play something like Rook
the E3 sort of a passive defense defend
the D3 Pawn this way or try to go for
Rook to B1 to go for an active defense
with Rook to B1 uh follow with Rook to
B7 but he plays Pawn to G3 and now it's
uh it's just weird she does have the
option of capturing this Pawn uh then he
can get his King into the game or she
can capture the pawn on D3 she captures
the pawn on D3 and okay Rook D3 you
can't go Rook to D1 uh it seems like you
could then the Knight moves you can
capture on D6 the problem is if you go
here uh then just Knight you have to
check and you blunder The Rook so here
with it goes Rook to E3 now comes Knight
to C1 and King to G2 the king now comes
into the game with Bishop to B8 uh also
adding a Defender to the D6 Pawn Plus if
you get the bishop to C7 you will very
nicely be controlling this Knight and C4
we have Rook to E1 and now comes Knight
the A2 going after the C3 pawn and
there's really no good way of Defending
in that pawn other than putting the Rook
to E3 but with it really doesn't want to
put his Rook on E3 he goes Rook to B1
and active one
a way of Defending uh Rook to B7 check
is coming and the idea is yes if you
capture on C3 then Rook the B7 check and
now after King to F6 something like
Knight the B6 may be with ideas of Rook
captures here followed by Rook captures
and knights the D7 with check a winning
material so while it's perfectly fine
you can still play King of the G6 here
she decides to avoid all this by just
playing Bishop to C7 and okay now with
it uh skewers the bishop here we have
Rook to B7 and now King to D7 defending
and now the problem is Knight to G5 now
how are you defending all of this again
there are threats of Road captures
Bishop followed by Knight captures and
E6 with check well well it looks scary
it's really not uh jio engine is
completely winning in this position but
you have to find a particular move so
feel free to pause the video and try to
find the absolute best move for black
here while I give you a couple of
seconds
so uh for those of you who were able to
do it congratulations on sporting this
very calm and uh well calm but active
move and for those of you who just want
to enjoy the show it is Rook the B8 this
is the move that solves all of her
problems and now you don't have to worry
about
um falling for any sort of fork uh here
the problem is if you trade Rook capture
some B8 then just Bishop captures and
once um Avid starts bringing the king
into the game you will lose the C3 Pawn
there's no way to defend that pawn and
now if you count the material uh Jew
engine is up three pawns and of course
three pawns is too much for anyone to
handle so vidit has to avoid this he
plays Rook day seven now okay he's still
keeping the bishop at Bay he's attacking
the A6 Pawn but now just Knight captures
on C3 we have Pawn to A5 defending the
the pawns from Knight captures on A4 but
now Rook to B4 putting pressure on the
Knight and also if the Knight moves then
the E4 Pawn will hang as well so Knights
the B6 with check now at least the uh
um uh he wins the E6 Pawn King to C6 and
now Knight captures and E6 going after
the bishop here but now the bishop did a
sufficient job defending the bishop will
now be traded for a night Bishop
captures trading down eight captures
with King captures on B6 and now Rook
captures on G7 she captures an E4 Knight
captures an E4 King to F3 and now Pawn
to D5 just defending here and now you
can see those pawns are starting to
March forward uh best thing to do here
would be just to resign with it will
continue for a few more moves The Rook
to G6 now Rook the B3 check we have King
to G2 Rook the B2 check king of three
now even Rook to F2 with check King to
E3 and now of course Rook to F6 stopping
any and all counter play now you have to
trade here uh Avid decides to trade with
Knight to a f8 so just a rook captures
on G6 Knight captures and G6 and even
Knight captures on G3 so uh grabbing all
of the material Knight captures an E5
and just spawn to A5 and he was in this
position on move 51 that visited
Gujarati uh resigned the game as there
is nothing more to be done here you are
down three pawns and it's merely a
matter of advancing those pawns there's
really no counter play here and of
course it would be uh it would be crazy
to continue playing this so really an
interesting game she absolutely
demolished him and uh by the time I'm
making this video uh only her uh
Juvenile and Pregnant are on two out of
two so on a 100 after two rounds we'll
see what happens in the rest of the
tournament uh but as I understand that
she is the only woman uh playing in the
tournament so that will be very
interesting to see if she is able to
continue playing into this level it's
pretty much a a perfect game if it did
play a couple of fishy moves uh but she
really took advantage of them and just
you know won the game like it was
nothing uh so yeah there we have it
thank you for suggesting that first game
that we are covering from the sixth
edition of the Char Jack Masters we'll
see uh what happens in the rest of the
tournament and really you have to wonder
in this position I mean you've played C3
you went for the main line of the Joker
piano and you've lost with white uh I
mean maybe maybe there are other moves
one could consider here but it's still
too early it's only 2023 I think maybe
like 2025 we will be discussing some
other moves here so yeah that's the game
hope you guys enjoyed it I would like to
thank Amazon Blake Turner Peter Martin
of AMD recent Enthusiast group and
golfsoftware.com for a contribution to
my channel thank you a lot I really
appreciate it as usual you can check two
of my previous videos here and thank you
for watching and I will see you soon
continuing the coverage of this
wonderful event and everything else that
happens in the Chess World so thank you
all I will see you soon and have an
excellent rest of your day